and then came time for the VR segment so
we saw a bunch of Eagle flight you know
palmer luckey on stage is I've never
expected I'd see you know eagles flying
over rabbit being shoutcast it on the
Internet yeah it was insane I mean there
was no rabbit but that was that that one
rabbit yeah but like the way they were
treating it like it's some sort of
eSports and like palmer luckey with his
weird science I advantage like just
playing it over the next big eSport yeah
what sandals you guys are wearing
compare sandals but like it looked okay
yeah it's it's good that you're always
in motion because when you slow down and
look around you like wow this game is
very bare bones but its stylized enough
to be kind of visually striking when
you're flying through it yeah but yeah I
don't know how long that premise is
going to be fun for I guess you could
make it interesting and extend this life
by creating loads of different maps and
that kind of stuff but hmm I don't know
how I feel about you know competitive
eagle flights knows you need like six
people to have binoculars and this year
would actually get a good game up yeah
there you could play online but yeah I'm
with you the gameplay seems kind of
thing I don't know how much you could
really do it more a little potty
training then put it back constant
screeching from Eagles so it's great oh
you meant palmer luckey all right I
thought that was Palmer is also dead
yeah but then there are the VR games of
course Star Trek myself video feature
with Karl Urban Jeri Ryan and levar
burton who I basically Star Trek the
game look it kind of looks like if
you've played that iphone game is it I
brought it down team space team on my
phone it's space team meets meets
yelling it working or everybody's all
the talking about yeah fun and fast yeah
it's basically a mixture of that which M
is like what I was saying earlier like
we need substantial experiences but
that's kind of I think might just kind
of be creeping up to that like because
space team was a very simple game
footage in groups it was very very fun
and and he had a lot of longevity to it
I played it a whole lot and it's clear
that they took inspiration from space
team like it's very obvious that they're
doing that
I mean yeah yeah and yeah steam was
itself a kind of parody on the kind of
Star Trek on the bridge you know telling
people what to do that kind of thing did
kind of laugh a little bit when the VAR
Burton's that the graphics are great
yeah worthy but not charming yeah oh no
seriously I mean I'm a big Trek fan so I
was like